this part just looks like the cake is
like I'm diarrhea or something
how do I feel about wedding I personally
don't like them I'm so iffy about
weddings I've been engaged for almost
four years and the idea of planning a
wedding I don't even have the energy to
like think about it not saying that I
should be married at this age but every
time I see that a friend is getting
engaged on Facebook and then has their
wedding it's just you know that quick
reminder that okay like I have not made
it there yet going to weddings is so
expensive and you have maybe like six or
seven weddings to go to that whole
season and it totally adds up it's time
off of work it's plane tickets I will
probably continue hating them until I
have my own I don't really care about
wedding cake I love wedding cake that's
like the best part of wedding right like
the cake like a wedding is one of the
only times where you're really gonna eat
like some good ass cake
how are you at like baking and stuff am
I about to bake a wedding cake oh my god
you're gonna make me bake a wedding cake
oh Lord
here we go I get to decorate a cake shut
up oh my god
this is giant oh my god I'm so excited I
have my Pinterest board for this I'm
kind of nervous because I'm also not
artistic at all
I feel like Gordon Ramsay's about to
come out and yell at me for whatever I'm
gonna do to this cake I've never
decorated a cake before I'm actually
really excited about this this might be
my second job now this comes out really
well
edible spray paint I feel like that just
be a disaster I feel like if you had to
sell your wedding though people would be
looking at you like how cheap are you
really all right now I'm painting it all
gold because I feel like a family
hopefully they don't mind my fingers
getting all over this I'm gonna be
something different on each layer this
can just be oriole I used to work at
Dairy Queen I was not allowed to
decorate the cakes oh my god I think I
use a whole bottle alright this looks
pretty shitty I'm gonna write love on
here that's what weddings are all about
oh yeah this is legit one time I tried
to decorate a cake it was a disaster I'm
gonna make this as if Oprah was gonna
eat this cake genius you're watching
genius if Oprah says she doesn't need to
get married then I don't need to get
married either God Baker's like work
really hard like my hand is tired and
I've been doing this like 45 second cool
guys this was my attempt at all
so that's what we're gonna say that is
oh it's so bad he was on falling oh
that's not I was hoping was gonna be
like droopier like it's just gonna get
really messy no no I'm just painting the
cake I touched the cake again and they
mess up the green frosting how can I fix
this where are you running wedding cake
on Italy there's that wedding right I've
never been fired from a job but if my
manager at Dairy Queen some be peeling
up from mistake frostings I don't think
I'd be employed there anymore feel like
this would be one of those weird
weddings that you see like on tumblr oh
my god hey myself you know what we're
gonna make this work first rule of Dairy
Queen if you can't fix it you just like
throw stuff on it this isn't working I
think this looks good
or if it doesn't look good it at least
looks like it tastes good it's hard
people who professionally make cakes are
so talented I mean I would have this on
my wedding because as long as the cake
inside was delicious like who cares
right you're just gonna like poop it out
okay this is the cake that you buy if
there's no other cake left in the shop
and your previous wedding cake was
dropped by like the groomsmen you want
cake like this at your wedding uh I
would have this as a backup cake
I am super embarrassed about this I
think my mom would be disappointed I
think Gordon Ramsay would be
disappointed looking at this if I were
to have a wedding cake if I needed to
plan it right now would be the opposite
of whatever I'm doing